Salut ! Aujourd'hui, nous sommes le 30 Juillet
et c'est la dernère vidéo du mois de Juillet, mais aussi
la dernière vidéo de cet été.
Pourquoi ? Ben écoutez, je vais vous le dire tout de suite.
Pour 2 raisons qui DEVRAIENT vous intéresser! Et en plus, à la fin de la vidéo
je vais vous dire quelque-chose qui devrait ENCORE PLUS vous intéresser !
Je fais clairement beaucoup trop de gestes ...
La première raison, c'est que; souvenez-vous, cet été, je devais
pas faire de vidéos du tout pour préparer des gros projets de la rentrée,
une sorte de renouveau de la chaîne.
Oui! Alors on a vu dans l'introduction de 20 secondes durant 20 vidéos,
ça on avait compris!
Et pour PAS vous laisser sans rien justement,
je vous avais préparé cette surprise de faire une vidéo tous les 2 jours, sur un format très court.
Mais en fait, je crois que ça marche pas comme idée.
Parce-que si je mettais pas l'intro qui expliquait, alors
Tout le monde croyait que la chaîne c'était devenu ça.
Quand je mettais l'intro, au contraire, une partie d'entre vous
en avait marre de l'avoir et disait ON A COMPRIS!
Et assez majoritairement, vous trouviez les vidéos pas assez complètes, fournies.
Ce qui était justement la base de ce concept:
de faire des vidéos d'une ou deux minutes.
La deuxième raison est beaucoup plus intéressante: c'est que durant tout ce mois de Juillet
j'ai beaucoup écrit et pensé à ce que l'on allait faire sur la chaîne maintenant.
Le truc qui va vous plaire, c'est qu'entre autres, on va revenir à des gros fondamentaux.
Quand je mentalise des gens, quand je vous explique
un tour de mentalisme que vous pouvez refaire,
quand je vous donne des astuces sur la mémoire...
Mais dans des formats encore plus variés, plus travaillés,
et pour ça, plus prévus.
Parce-qu'ici, depuis le premier Janvier 2016
on pense à sa vidéo deux jours avant, un jour avant, voire le matin.
donc c'est toujours plus tendu et parfois j'ai des bonnes idées
que j'ai pas le temps de mettre en place
un exemple très simple qui va vous spoiler un peu
mais depuis, depuis presque qu'un an je veux faire
une vidéo d'hypnose sur la chaîne
connaissant bien et pratiquant l'hypnose je ne veux pas faire n'importe quoi
je veux vous faire quelque chose d'assez varié
et d'assez précis aussi et bien si je prend du temps en août
je vais pouvoir la réaliser et elle sortira en septembre
et pour tous ces projets et toutes ces idées
il me faut un maximum de temps
au mois d'août. afin de créer une sorte de temps d'avance
donc c'est parti, pas de vidéo  en août
et une reprise en septembre
et alors c'est là que ça devrait vous plaire
j'ai prévu un nouveau planning, alors attention l'annonce est très solennel
*Musique présidentielle*
à partir du premier septembre, il y aura une vidéo tous les mardis
et tous les vendredis à 15H sur la chaîne
les mardis et les vendredis  à 15H et un nouveau rendez-vous
en plus, ça c'est bonus
chaque dernier mercredi du mois à 20h20
Les vrais savent
il y aura un live sur la chaîne voilà ça commence le premier septembre
donc d'ici là évidemment il n'y aura plus de vidéo sur la chaîne
mais on doit être grosso modo à 450 vidéos
si vous venez d'arriver, vous pouvez regarder, il y a plein plein de choses qui ont été traitées
si vous faites partie des anciens vous pouvez revoir les vidéos
et quoi qu'il arrive je vais être actif sur insta, snapchat, twitter, facebook
vous avez tout les liens dans la description
et puis si l'on profitait de l'été pour bouquiner un peu je sais pas
par exemple un livre qui va vous donner toutes les bases sur le mentalisme
et dont le lien et la vidéo de présentation seraient dans la description, par exemple
mais j'ai tellement hâte d'être en septembre pour vous faire voir tout ce que j'ai préparé pour la chaîne
en attendant passez un bon mois d'août profitez du soleil
faites vous plaisir, déconnectez et donc rendez-vous
le premier septembre ça sera donc un vendredi
ça sortira à 15h
CIAO!
Sous- titre par : Etienne Lamole Loïs Pouyé, Wolfenstein's gamer